identifying analyzing and correcting
incidents are essential to the ops
team's job it should go without saying
that these tasks are critical to the
success of your company's online
services and overall application
performance
but that's not the whole picture
monetization to cloud-based applications
has introduced opportunities and if
you're not careful it can introduce
incident management headaches
hi i'm dan keen from ibm cloud let's
look at the top three ops troublemakers
number one complex deployments while
traditional monitoring tools are good at
solving specific problems they present a
fragmented view of the enterprise
infrastructure to solve complex
incidents of modern workloads you need
end-to-end visibility
number two alert overload
dynamic distributed components speed app
delivery but more change can lead to
more incidents and finally number three
lack of visibility
related events are frequently not
correlated across silos this opened the
door to a time consuming whodunit
mystery to find the root cause of an
incident
of course your dev and ops team want the
same thing to assure app performance and
keep customers happy
but cloud adoption has changed the
balance
how did devops become more work for ops
i'll quickly explain and cover how apps
can help rebalance it
cloud architectures mean more and
smaller service components versus
traditional monolithic architectures
however the software development life
cycle hasn't changed it's still build
deploy run and manage
your devs love the increased speed of
the earlier coding phases but it comes
at the cost of operational complexity
how do you keep the speed benefit while
minimizing the post delivery impacts on
your ops team
let me introduce a smarter more modern
tool for the job ibm cloud pack for
watson ai ops
it identifies problems and assigns
incidents to the right person with the
context they need
even in dynamic and complex environments
root cause candidates are identified
quickly
okay with that review out of the way
let's get back to the headaches i
mentioned earlier
first up complex deployments
correlation and contextualization are at
the heart of ibm cloud pack for watson
ai ops
it ingests data from logs system metrics
alerts and events it flags potential
anomalies including real-time
topological information
your team gains a holistic understanding
of an incident based on ai driven
reasoning this gets you the incident's
root cause faster and keeps you from
walking down blind alleys
next is everyone's nightmare alert
overload
ibm cloud pack or was the app provides
algorithms and machine learning models
for anomaly detection it knows what's
normal and what's not to reduce false
alerts
so instead of getting an alert storm
originating from the same root cause
related alerts and events are
consolidated into one incident
the result is an early warning indicator
a sort of check engine light so the sre
can take proactive remedial action
finally to give your ops team the
visibility they need emerging incidents
that require the sre's attention are
surfaced via a chat ops interface like
slack
thanks to its built-in integration with
hundreds of ops tools
sres can launch in context the original
tool for further analysis
and to reduce the list of hedonic
candidates the dashboard highlights the
originating faulty component and
potentially impacted dependent
components
based on nlp analysis of similar
incidents ibm cloud pack for wasn't the
app suggests next best actions to remedy
the incident such as run books or other
predefined remedial actions
and to keep everyone on the same page it
includes an intelligent workflow to
support the op seems collaboration
towards resolution ok let's wrap this up
with ibm cloud pack for wasa apps you
get relief from incident headaches by
gaining insights to tackle complex
deployments consolidating alerts to
reduce false alarms and analyzing root
cause candidates through intelligent
workflow
imagine being able to reduce your it
costs in mttr by 50
ibm can help you get there
thanks for watching
if you'd like to see more videos like
this in the future please click like and
subscribe
if you want to learn more about ibm
cloud pack for watson ai ops check out
the links in the description